the faith in the polling industry right
now right is so poor that I feel like
the polls are probably going to be a lot
of people feel like the polls are going
to be off by more than they're going to
move over the next year right I mean we
could see essentially the same thing
over the next year the poll's saying
what they say and then oops it's it B
either Trump wins in a huge Landslide or
Biden somehow eeks it out I mean I think
there's all this this hopium right that
people are taking that well the polls
you can't believe the polls you can't
trust the polls you've got these insular
partisan Echo Chambers where people are
repeating them this stuff to themselves
every day and I'm like no as a pollster
I say no you can't necessarily take
everything we say as gospel right but uh
we need to have some grounding in
reality right you need to have some
common sense here